For those of you keeping score at home
last week was one for the Rubin report.
Record books are week.
Started off by interviewing Senator John
Mccain,
a war hero,
one of the longest serving members of
Congress,
and a Republican nominee for president
of the United States,
Senator Mccain and I had a frank
discussion on this year's election,
money and politics and foreign policy.
What struck me more than anything while
talking to the senator was whether you
agree or disagree with his political
opinions.
It's clear that he's really trying to
bridge the ideological divide and do
what he feels is right for the country.
The entire time I was talking to him,
I kept thinking,
what a better candidate,
senator mccain would be,
the any of the current contenders in the
gop rat race.
Immediately after interviewing Senator
Mccain,
I had the chance to interview loopnet.
Loopnet is a 23 year old engineering
student and an atheist fighting for
secular values in her homeland of Iraq.
Simply by talking to me about secularism
from the confines of her clothes
society.
She instantly became braver than pretty
much every person that I know.
I'm honored that she chose me as the
first public person to talk to and I'll
always be an ally for her,
whether she's in Iraq or wherever.
Life takes her while I was in awe of her
during the interview.
The most impactful part to me was when
we talked about some of the people that
we both admire,
including Sam Harris and Richard
Dawkins.
This portion of our chat illuminated
exactly what this show is about.
Ideas the same ideas that Sam and
Richard sparked in me.
A 39 year old guy born in Brooklyn,
living in Los Angeles,
also were sparked in Louisiana.
A 23 year old atheist in Iraq.
This shows you the true power of ideas,
good or bad.
Ideas can transcend nationality,
race,
or religion.
My final interview last week was with
the former leader of the English defense
league and now outspoken anti
immigration activist,
Tommy Robinson.
As I mentioned at the top of the show
last week,
I was hesitant to even talk to Tommy
because people might call me a bigot or
a racist.
Not only my glad that we did the
interview,
but I'm really proud of your reaction to
it,
whether on Youtube,
twitter,
or facebook.
You guys all kept the conversation going
after Tommy and I put it down.
It was complete and total confirmation
of last week's direct message being
afraid to talk and no longer be part of
the equation.
I have no doubt there is a real movement
happening right now.
People are absolutely sick of being
divided.
Conversation is the key to bringing us
together,
and that's why in one week I talked to a
man who was almost the leader of the
free world,
a woman who puts her life on the line to
say what she believes and another man
who is on a crusade of his own.
It's totally irrelevant whether I agree
with everything my guest say.
The important thing is to not be afraid
to hear them.
As the Internet brings us all closer
together,
we find ourselves connected with people
in a way that we could've only dreamt of
a couple years ago.
Despite that connection,
I still get messages from you or is
explaining that sometimes you guys are
afraid to say certain things to your
friends in real life or to post certain
articles on facebook for all to see if
lube a 23 year old in Iraq isn't afraid
to speak up,
then you guys can't be either.
There is no time for silence anymore.
Yeah,
there are genuinely bad people in the
world and sometimes talking to them
won't get you the results you want.
However,
you have to be brave enough to have the
conversation in the first place.
Don't let louder.
Voices with worst intentions drown you
out.
All right.
According to Wikipedia,
my guest this week is either the former
king of Mesopotamia or youtube,
or not afraid to speak his mind on
controversial topics.
That's right.
I have Carl Benjamin,
better known as Sargon of a cod on the
show.
Carl Sargon.
What do I call you?
Whichever you once.
I get cold both all day long.
So whichever one you're comfortable
with.
Sargon has sort of overtaken.
Carl.
There's sort of a Batman,
Bruce Wayne situation here.
Right?
You know,
like that kind of is actually.
Yeah,
it's the name song on his definitely
traveled before me in many places where
progressives,
a tense congregates
aggressives I'm shocked that you didn't
say regressives,
but we'll get to that momentarily.
So,
uh,
before we get into all the deep stuff
and the,
and the topics and the meat of this,
I want people to get to know you a
little bit because I think it's sort of
just recently that you're showing your
face more.
You're out there more,
your name's getting out there a little
bit more.
So how did Carl Benjamin Becomes Argon?
Have a guide.
Um.
Oh,
that's an interesting.
It's an interesting story.
It's not actually that interesting as
well.
That will just make it interesting.
How about that?
I'll try,
I'll try and I'll try and fabricates let
me know.
Basically about.
So about two and a half years ago.
I know you when you know,
when you're on the Internet,
you ended up just choosing a Monica that
you sign into places with and I just
happened to like the historical figure
of song and he was an interesting
figure.
I like the sound of the name and you
know,
I saw,
I was just using that and I had signed
up to youtube.
I'm in 2010 just to upload some videos
of myself with an ancient sling,
you know,
the sort of,
uh,
I made one call the historical sort of
documents and I tested it out and it's
that you can see why they're dangerous
weapons or thing.
And then a few days later I was
basically getting really,
really worried about lead the sort of
political climate in the left eye was
starting to see more and more often I'm
just my,
my own principles being completely
violated.
And it was really,
really,
really worried and it was thing that was
genuinely started ignoring me because,
I mean I would see people arguing for
arguing against people's freedom of
speech or they would be arguing against
the socratic system.
So some Lama and everyone would seem to
be going along with it this,
this was it,
you know,
there was so many people going,
yeah,
that's exactly how we should do things.
Those,
those Palak thinking course.
I totally disagree and I disagree on
such a fundamental level.
I have to say something and so I found
myself just motivated sort of right
around just like under five minute
scripts or something and then read them
with a very,
very bad microphone.
It's all about the mic.
It really is.
It's,
it's a,
it's a magician's trick on this,
but I have just the cheap on microphone.
It was really,
really terrible quality and I'd read
these ideas and they started gaining.
Some teams have started.
People started subscribing to my channel
and stuff and looking back,
now I'm thinking,
God,
they were really.
That was a little full bearings there
about my technical skill and what I was
saying,
but I guess some people agreed with what
was saying because now I've got um,
I've just lost a quarter of a million
subscribers.
Uh,
yeah.
Now I do this full time and it's a,
it's a wonderful thing to be doing is
fighting for my principals professional.
So I love that.
I love that because as I say on the show
every week,
what I'm trying to do here is make this
about ideas.
And that's really what you were talking
about,
you were hearing bad ideas and then you
want it to beat them with better ideas
and clearly it's working because you got
over 250,000
subscribers.
And,
and when I had my personal awakening
because everyone knows at this point,
you know,
I've always considered myself liberal.
Then I was in the progressive world,
which I now see as some sort of mental
disorder.
Um,
but when I was having my awakening out
of that,
uh,
everyone online said to me,
you've got to talk to Sargon.
Uh,
so my,
so my first question to you before we
get into the heavy stuff is,
did you study politics?
What brought you into the political
realm?
I didn't.
It was,
um,
it was just watching the news I guess,
and just watching you know,
popular.
I mean,
I,
I used to be,
I used to be a big fan of the young
Turks.
Um,
I used to consider myself progressive
until I met progressive's.
And like you said,
I couldn't believe the things they were
saying it,
it really struck me as some sort of
mental disorder.
Yeah.
Why would they start saying things like
this and.
Yeah,
and then I,
then I,
I,
I still find myself floundering on my
own because the,
you know,
there's,
I,
I'm not a conservative and I can't,
I can't bring myself to subscribe to
conservative ideals and they just
didn't.
They didn't work for me.
I don't,
I don't believe in them.
Um,
and so I was basically on my own,
you know,
everyone I knew was,
it was a liberal,
was quite happy to ignore the
foundational principles of liberalism in
order to,
in order to push progressivism,
furthering.
The more I,
the more I've learned about
progressivism,
the more I realize it's really used
liberalism as a Trojan horse to they've
said,
oh,
we liberals or progressives and I mean
on the,
on the subsequent.
They're not necessarily our group for
different things.
It's really the methods,
the problem.
It's not necessarily the goals.
Um,
but yeah,
they,
they heavily use the terms
interchangeably and they are not
interchangeable.
That's all.
Yeah.
So let's,
let's unpack that a little bit.
So I've heard you say you refer to
yourself as a classic liberal,
and the more that I've been doing this,
I mean that's really where I feel at
home too.
I think now I have some really strong
libertarian leanings also,
but there's,
there's some,
there's some play there,
there's some common ground there.
But what is classic liberalism mean to
you?
Um,
well it's just the instance,
the basic values that came out of the
alignment,
the civil liberties,
political freedom,
freedom of expression,
freedom of association,
Economic Freedom,
representative democracy,
the rule of law.
It's always just,
there is no argument against these
ideas.
These are great ideas that universal
ideas,
you know,
everyone is protected under these ideas.
Unlike with progressivism web,
the first thing they will do is
demarcates a group and they will say,
right women,
black people,
gay people,
these people need special treatment and
special treatment will involve the
infringement of your personal rights.
And that is where I have a problem
because if we all ascribe to these same
rights,
hey,
we're all being treated as equals B,
nobody ends up losing their rights.
And I don't have a point seat.
Should I do?
I think I've covered the reasons.
Yeah,
that,
that was pretty good.
So this is sort of a,
an example of the road to hell is paved
with good intentions,
right?
Because this is where I've seen,
I know a lot of progressives,
a lot of them won't talk to me anymore.
People that I that were my good friends
only,
you know,
six,
eight months ago that won't talk to me
anymore.
But I believe that for the most part,
and we're going to get into some of the
really dangerous ones.
But I think for the most part,
people that consider themselves
progressive,
most of the people that are going to
Bernie Sanders rallies I think are good
people.
I think their intentions are correct.
So we're really talking about the
methodology here,
right?
Yeah.
The,
the,
there are a few.
The problem is you have a bunch of.
You have a bunch of motivating factors
that kind of coalesce and in mixed in
with that,
you have the more sort of a punisher
aspects of people who can see where this
is going because a lot of it involves
giving the benefit of the doubts so
people who you would otherwise
necessarily be skeptical to.
People making.
I mean,
for example,
rape laws,
one of the big progressive pushes and it
is,
is to have it so the victim quotes
unquotes,
the alleged victim is believed and
therefore the burden of proof becomes
lead on the person who's being accused
rather than on the accuser and they do
this by the use of statistics.
They say,
oh,
well,
you know,
I can't remember the numbers,
but something like under five percent of
accused rapist go to jail or something
like that,
and therefore they assume that there is
a massive problem with the system.
That 95 percent of accused rapist also
actual rapists and therefore just being
let off through a bad system.
But the thing is,
hey,
we don't know.
We have no idea how many of the people
who are accused are actually legitimate
rapists and deserve to be condemned for
it and convicted for,
but secondly,
what we're doing that is reversing the
system because at the moment what we
have as a system that isn't perfect but
can deliver justice in a reliable way,
you know,
we,
we can be quite sure that the people
going to jail,
probably aunt innocent,
you know,
we've been through a rigorous rigorous
trial.
The burden of proof is on the accuser.
They've managed to prove beyond
reasonable doubt and you know that's
fine because that way you're going to
get the minimum number of people who
didn't do anything wrong,
being punished as if they did something
wrong.
Whereas to flip the script on,
that would mean that you now have a
system that is inherently unjust,
that might be able to deliver justice on
occasion.
The occasion being the person being
accused is on camera somewhere else at
the time that they're supposed to have
been doing the rape or something like
that.
You know,
it's not sort of thing.
It's,
it would be incidental justice.
You know,
you couldn't rely on it because you
don't presume the innocence of the
people being accused that guilt is being
presumed and it's being done like say,
Oh,
good motives.
The idea that,
you know,
well,
we don't want to cool the victims lies
and it's like,
no,
I don't want to call the victim a liar
either,
but it's one of those points where
you're on the horns of a dilemma and you
have no choice but to take a responsible
course of action for safety of someone
who hasn't done anything wrong.
Right.
So,
all right,
so there,
there's a lot there that I want to go.
I've been preparing for this.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
you're jumping.
You're though I knew that that's how
this conversation was going to go
because there's so much to talk about.
And then these things are always
inextricably linked.
That's what I found whenever I'm talking
about anything related to sort of
regressive ideology.
And then when you start talking about
feminism and Islam,
Islam and all these things,
uh,
they're,
they're all so inextricable,
inextricably linked.
Um,
so let's,
let's jump into Gamergate for a second
and then we'll get back to some of that
stuff because Gamergate,
I think is one of the things that really
sort of put you on the map.
And even by saying the word Gamergate,
I've made people crazy.
We know this now.
I've discussed it with a couple people
I've had Milo Yiannopoulos on.
I've talked about it with Christina Hoff
summers.
But you,
yourself,
you are a true Gamer,
correct?
Yes,
I am indeed a true Gamer.
What are you playing these days?
I play a game called oxygen level of
volt.
Most,
um,
I actually have my own server where I
pay for a sub or I get to run around
killing the tool dinosaurs.
That's great.
Wow.
Well thank you for taking a moment from
slaying dinosaurs to uh,
to join me here.
Uh,
but yeah,
you've really been in the Gamergate
thing and I think are considered sort of
an expert on it.
So can you give me like a two,
three minute explanation of what
Gamergate is?
And I know that's almost impossible
because it seems like it's something
different to everybody.
It is,
is it,
I can give you my version of what it is,
but like you say,
it is different for everybody and you're
going to get people who are going to say
that's not what Gamergate,
his and one not.
So,
um,
for me it is,
it's a very definite reaction to
regressives infiltrating the video game
media.
Now this is something that we saw.
We've still happening over the course of
about five years where they were just in
criminal,
larger and larger numbers of them would
be hired at various gaming publications
and then they would start writing
articles like all these video games,
sexist.
Why are these video games was soldiers.
There are no Trans People Nisa d games.
This is racist.
This is,
you know,
the,
the standard regressive lines.
Yeah.
And they would be promoting very famous
feminist like Anita Sarkeesian or when
people with.
And I don't,
I don't know,
I don't want to sound mean,
but very few real credentials in the
video game industry mean like Zoe Quinn.
When the,
the,
uh,
Franz Ferdinand of game of gates,
she made a,
a free.
Um,
did you,
did you ever have those choose your own
adventure book?
I loved,
choose your own adventure.
I probably had everyone likes,
right?
Yeah.
Basically that's what she had made.
She had made a digital tutors rent
adventure book.
It was all old tanks.
No,
no,
nothing else in it.
It can take him very long,
but it was about learning to deal with
depression and I've never had depression
and so I can't judge the game on that
metric.
So I'm on that.
I'm sure it's very good.
But your average game of this wasn't
really a game.
It wasn't a fail state,
you know,
it wasn't,
there wasn't really into complaint.
It was more like an interactive Nova,
which is again,
it's in itself is fine,
but the gaming press,
because she was a prominent feminist and
regressive,
she got unbelievable amounts of coverage
and I mean when I say unbelievable me,
any amounts of coverage,
but it's more than you would expect.
And so people were kind of getting sick
of the agenda being pushed on them.
And it's the same as it needs to appease
him when he'd suck easy in.
Did a kickstarter,
it was everywhere.
Everyone knew about it,
and yet everyone also knew that the
argument that she was presenting where
half truths they would cherry pick,
they were.
She was finding individually examples
that didn't really represent the gaming
industry or any evil,
you know,
subsections of the gaming industry.
I'm presenting them as if they were a
categoric statement on the condition of
the entire gaming industry.
And so everyone was really kind of
annoyed by this point,
especially as the way that these people
work is by running a pure emotions.
So almost everything they say is
fundamentally accusatory.
They would say things like,
you're a sexist or a racist if you like
these games.
There aren't enough black people in this
game,
rotten of women in this game or gay
people or the sort of thing.
And if you're enjoying it,
you're a bad person.
Whereas most people are thinking,
well,
just how.
Just just make the games you want to
make.
Right?
But no,
that's not what these people are
interested in whatsoever.
And so it got to the point where that
Zoe Quinn was colts having an affair
with her boss who was involved in video
games and also a journalist called
Nathan Grayson.
And the video game industries presses
always been corrupt.
I mean that it's always been cropped.
It's come out of a hobby press.
It's always been really,
really bad.
Um,
but
so when you say corrupt,
just to pause for one second,
when you say corrupt,
I mean things like,
you know,
people paying off the magazine writers
so that they'd get better reviews on the
game.
So they'd sell more games.
I mean,
real corrupt stuff.
Yeah.
And a hold of it's in your face as well.
So you go to a video game,
a online magazine,
I'm the backdrop would be the
advertisement for gate then would be
reviewed in the sense of color.
You know,
it's not,
it's not even trying to hide it,
but for the most part nobody really
cared because they weren't being preachy
about,
you know,
they were trying to sell you video
games.
I'm asked,
well,
people with death and that full of
nobody was that bothered.
But then the regressives turned up and
started being corrupt in a whole
different way instead of instead of
being motivated by money,
which I suppose is to their credit,
they were motivated by ideology and so
now they would hire people into
positions and promote things that were
all based on cronyism.
It was all their friends and family
members and no,
they would.
They would push everything to do with
our agenda and people realistically,
people have just been really,
really sick.
Then just when they were tied to this
phone,
moralism tied to being told that they
were bad people even though you didn't.
Obviously none of these people are
actually bad people,
you know,
nobody knows who all these people and
yeah,
they're being,
they're being prejudged before anything
happens.
And they got to the point where people
like looking at it enough,
you know,
this has got to stop.
And that's what that was.
Basically it was called the Quinn
spirasi solid.
And then the video game press instead of
turning around and saying something
like,
okay,
fair enough.
We haven't been doing our due diligence.
You know,
we,
a lot of them are professional trained
journalists like Steven that's a
telephone Kentucky,
his master's degree in journalism and
he's there saying,
well,
do we have to be objective?
What's the need for objective
journalism?
And so you can instantly see the
problems that were in the air and in the
video game industry.
Yeah.
And I know we can,
we can really go down the rabbit hole
with this and we could,
we could spend three hours with this,
but I think that's.
I think that's a nice little beginning
piece of it.
But what I really find fascinating about
it and why I've brought it up several
times is because the same things that
you're talking about,
how the regressive sort of infiltrated
this and turned something that had
nothing to do with sexism or racism or
any of these things.
They made it about that.
And I think when I was on your show,
I was saying how I,
you know,
I used to be a huge gamer.
I'm not that much anymore,
but I liked the community and I do play
some games here and there.
But like,
you know,
I played grand theft auto and yeah,
you could steal a car and punch a hooker
and people would say,
well that's against women,
but you could also punch your man.
So should they only have it that you'd
only punch men.
I mean even the logic behind it doesn't
really stand to critique
and the,
there is no winning ignorant.
So the point is,
it's all in the school.
It's either you are this thing or this
thing,
you don't even realize it,
you know,
and there's no falsifiability is one of
the hypotheses.
But the,
the,
the main problem,
if you think about it,
like with grand theft auto.
So like what are the options?
Not include women in the game.
No way they'd,
they'd freak out if you couldn't put
women in the game,
right?
Or you can have the women not being able
to be treated like men again,
that'd be freaking out.
That's not equal at all.
So what I mean,
what are you going to have?
You're going to have women and suddenly
it just can't be damaged or you know,
you,
they will not allow you to treat women
like men.
You know,
you can't beat up women,
you can't,
but you can be tough men.
And so you're,
you're in this position where you've got
no when,
you know there's no good answer and
that's how they want it.
They want you dancing to that team.
Yeah.
And that's what,
that's what's so fascinating about this
and why I think it's so related to the
political situation with the
regressives.
And I also think that's why Gamergate
blew up the way it did because gamers
generally are going to skew a little
younger than the people that are solely
interested in politics.
So because of that,
I think it was this group of people who
had never been used to being attacked or
silenced before and they were young and
they were online and they were ready to
coalesce around something.
And I think that's what made it so,
so magical or something,
you know,
Gamers,
gamers actually loan been the demon in
the,
uh,
in the bedroom.
Then I felt like the American Christians
in the late nineties,
early two thousands,
there was Hillary Clinton under Joe
journeymen actually brought legislation
to try and try and sort of sense of
video games.
So this is another reason I would never
vote for Hillary.
I mean,
I don't think anyone ever should.
She's a corporate shell.
Don't vote for Hillary,
but she,
the ending,
there were so many reasons not to.
Basically
we can get into that.
Gamers are actually quite familiar with
being attacked politically because of
that hobby.
Even though there hasn't been a single
study that's ever really conclusively
proven anything about Video Games.
In fact,
there are,
there are dozens that say,
well,
there is no connection between video
games and anything.
You know,
if you look at the statistics,
the rise of video games just coincided
with the dissenter violence.
So I mean,
I'm not saying that connected,
but it's one of those things that there
is literally nothing to show the video
games or doing anything wrong.
In fact,
there's quite a lot to show that doing a
lot of things.
Wow.
Well,
I remember that.
I think maybe it was around 91 or 92
when Joe Lieberman was leading that,
that fight against video games.
I think it was because of mortal Kombat.
I was playing it on Sega Genesis at the
time and I would come home from school
and play that for hours with my friends.
I never ripped anyone skull out with
their spine attached to it,
you know what I mean?
Not once now.
I tried once,
but I,
yeah,
I never successfully did it.
So that says something actually,
I think you can prove that it probably
helps people in a more healthy way than
some of their anger and frustration.
Don't you think?
No,
I think the multiplayer games on there,
you know,
they get,
they get groups of guys to hang out and
do something that's not dangerous or
violent,
you know,
and I think about it.
I mean,
when I was a kid,
if one playing video games,
we were on the streets,
it was better for us to be at home
playing video games than to not be
playing video games.
So,
uh,
I,
I honestly can't see where the
objections come from.
You know,
it's the same with anything like
dungeons and dragons in the ats or music
in the seventies,
you know,
video games in the nineties and two
thousands there.
There is always something that we,
you know,
poke clutching,
moral majority or so they would like to
position themselves as has got to rail
against something.
And ironically that was always the
religious rights,
you know,
that was always the highly religious
authoritarian.
Right now it is the highly regressive
authoritarian left.
Yeah.
And this is the horseshoe theory that we
talk about all the time that the
extremes on both sides come together.
Alright,
so last thought on Gamer Gate,
you know,
the other thing that I think is really
nice about the community is that people
who are gamers,
it doesn't matter what race you are,
it doesn't matter what religion you are,
what sex or sexuality,
any of the little dividing boxes that
the left wants to put us in.
It doesn't matter what you are.
And that's why the community's so
strong.
So then when,
when these people that are writing these
articles say,
well gamers or sexist or gamers or
racist,
it actually,
it literally has no meaning because it's
as diverse a community as you could
possibly put out there,
right?
Yeah,
I mean it.
You literally can't tell by playing a
video game what race agenda The people
you're playing with are because everyone
gets to choose their own Avatar,
but it gets customized.
Their name,
you know,
that the only way you'd know is by voice
chat know.
So for the vast majority of people
playing video games is not paid to
identity politics.
And you know,
what's interesting is the regressive
academics actually did.
They spent a lot of times or planning
their assault on video games and they
spent time doing research and there was
an academic feminist academic called
Adrian who did a series of studies not
based on particularly large sample
sizes,
but large enough I would say to at least
give you the impression that they're
going the wrong direction because her
conclusions and she was someone looking
for a way to sort of,
you know,
crack open the video game industry with
a good reason to attack it.
She found that basically a mini games
didn't need diversity.
Video Games had diversity,
which meant that,
you know,
and that in itself what,
where,
where does the regressive begin their
plan of attack if the thing they're
attacking is already diverse,
you know.
And so basically it,
it led to her reframing the study she
had already conducted in a different
way.
And the,
uh,
the language is very opaque,
but basically she was not happy that
there was a plurality of markets.
And now I personally think a plurality
of markets is a wonderful thing.
I think,
you know,
if a video,
if you want video games about the
Japanese Hentai great,
that's your business.
I'm not interested in that.
I will.
I will video games about killing
dinosaurs.
That's great.
That's my niche.
And everyone gets their own niche,
you know,
whereas the problem that they had is
that they wanted hedge ammonia overlap.
They didn't want a plurality of markets
because then you could have diverse
market,
you can have marcus on by this.
They won't say every market to be
controlled effectively by their
ideology.
And thankfully he's not going to happen.
Right.
So just to be clear about that.
So there are people that are probably
playing Mario Kart that have nothing to
do with the people that are playing the
games you're playing.
So it doesn't make sense even to lump
all those people together.
Absolutely.
I mean there will obviously be some
crossover in every,
every game genre,
but by and large you get people who have
different preferences and they play
different things.
Like I'm.
One of the things I would say,
one of the things they,
uh,
the big,
slightly polite as,
oh,
almost half of people playing video
games or women.
It's okay,
great,
but what are they playing?
They don't play call of duty,
you know,
they're not sitting there on their
xboxes but the headphones and running
around calling each other gay that
playing candy crush and Farmville,
which all perfectly valid forms of
entertainment and more power to them.
I want them to play the games they want
to play.
But these,
by,
you know,
by this point it doesn't justify
changing anything about the games I play
because of the games they play and vice
versa is true.
I don't want their games being changed
to suit me either.
You know,
that would be the last thing I would
want to impose on.
And so this is basically one of the
things the regressive left will always
do,
is use statistics and the most slippery
way possible in Atlanta lies damn lies.
And statistics really does apply it.
You,
I mean they,
they will use statistics to justify
anything.
So be be careful about the use of
statistics with the regressive left.
All right,
so you've given me a perfect lane
through Gamergate to talk about probably
your,
your other favorite thing to talk about,
or at least maybe your most
controversial thing to talk about,
which is feminism.
Uh,
so let's,
let's go there.
Let's talk a little feminism A.
I'm going to give you this in the most
broad sense.
Basically you don't like what the
feminist movement has become.
Is that fair to say?
Yes.
And the,
one of the dangers of talking about
feminism is that it's very often
conflated with women and this is done
through eight women who exactly you're a
misogynist.
Last thing you will hear if ever you
have any complaint about feminism,
um,
however,
I mean this is just obviously logically,
it's not,
it's nonsense.
Feminism itself as an ideology and
you've got male and female feminists and
you get people who are male and female
opposed to modern feminism.
So the idea that feminism is inherently
the same as women is ridiculous.
And the thing is,
even the fewer and fewer women every
year are identifying as feminists at the
moment in,
in America,
only about 18 percent of women identify
as feminists.
And I knew something about nine percent
of men,
whereas in,
in say the seventies,
it was similar as high as 40 percent.
So the feminist movement is honestly,
I think,
I don't think he's doing yourself any
favors.
I think it's gotten full regressive.
That's the problem.
Um,
you know,
I,
I would have no problem calling myself a
feminist if we were in the era of say,
second wave feminism.
We had some equity feminism to Christina
Hoff sommers oh,
Camille Paglia would be espousing this
whole equal rights,
equal pay or the sort of the sort of
things that you as any egalitarian would
be completely on board with and would
find absolutely no objection to.
I find that objection to.
But my problem is when we start getting
into the realms of,
well I mean shaming language for you
were misogynistic,
this you about you the other,
when you have any objection and quoters
or any,
anything like this,
you know,
and then you,
then you get into conspiracy theories,
patriarchy theory,
you know,
and then it becomes intersectional.
So now involves race and transsexuals
and homosexuals and now it's a karaoke.
This is an insult linking a series of
oppressions and privileges.
And really you realize that what you
want your luggage,
you say seeing is Marxist rhetoric.
It's all.
I mean if you read the communist
manifesto,
you understand modern feminism,
you know,
you were talking about the male
bourgeoisie and the female promaths
Harriet's and it's the same with black
and white,
straight and gay and all these sort of
things.
And I just don't ascribe to that because
it implies a shared experience that we
know men and women don't have.
You know,
I mean,
and not just men and women,
like black people,
any of Trayvon Martin did not have the
same life experiences as Barack Obama,
you know?
And so to say that being black is some
sort of inherent shared oppression that
they have is ridiculous,
you know,
it just,
it doesn't work.
And my main problem really is,
is that it's become anti individualistic
the.
I mean,
you get famous feminist like any sockies
and who will literally say things like,
um,
individuals,
women,
individual women's choices don't count.
What Matt says is,
what methods is feminism of the great,
you know,
something for the greater good feminism,
something.
I can't remember exactly how the quote
goes,
but it was just one of those things
where it's just like,
okay,
I,
I'm so totally against this,
that I think I would be prepared to
fight a civil war against,
you know,
these are so anti anti liberal
principles.
I can't stand them.
So in a way it's evolved to where it's
no longer first off,
women are a minority.
I think there's something like 50 slash
50,
one or 52 percent of the population,
but where,
where you should be for the minority and
a minority.
Uh,
what you're saying is that they're
fighting,
they're eliminating the minority in the
minority.
I think an example of that we could use
from the American political space would
be someone like Sarah Pailin.
Now,
I don't like the views that Sarah Pailin
espouses spouses at all,
but can you believe that?
Yeah.
I'm not a big fan of Sarah Pailin.
That being said,
she's obviously a very influential and
powerful and a self motivated woman.
So in a certain sense,
she's the ultimate,
uh,
goal of what a feminist should be.
But feminists hate her,
right?
Absolutely.
[inaudible].
She thinks wrong.
What's the problem?
She,
she doesn't spinals she doesn't espouse
a regressive ideology.
She doesn't.
I mean,
if she called herself a feminist,
fundamentally she wouldn't be invoking
Marxist ideas.
She would be invoking sorts of
libertarian ideas.
So the strength of the individual hard
work,
you know,
all these.
Honestly I think that,
you know,
they're not,
they're not bad ideas at all,
but she wouldn't be in the same camp as
say Gloria Steinem Steinem or bell hooks
or someone like that.
I don't.
It's weird talking about Marxism.
You know,
it's really weird because,
I mean almost no,
nobody really understands it these days
and any people understand it,
the academics and universities who teach
it,
and it is the manifesto is the third
most prescribed book in universities in
America.
Just seeing the communist manifesto.
Communism died everywhere.
But in the west,
it's so bizarre.
We fetishize these things,
right?
Absolutely.
People,
people who live under communism hates
communism,
they think is a terrible idea.
They know that.
I mean,
they,
they had secure at three in the morning
for milk and eggs,
you know,
they think is a terrible idea,
but the people in the west have never
lived through being put into practice
and so they don't understand it's,
you know,
they don't really viscerally understand
the real true nature of it I guess.
And so,
you know,
when you're sitting in a comfortable
house that's been built under
capitalistic system and you've got lots
of money and you've,
you're doing very well for yourself.
You thinking,
well,
maybe we should,
you know,
maybe maybe it's not such a bad idea and
it's,
you know,
but it's,
it's these principles that inform almost
everything about third wave feminism.
It's all about,
it's all about power dynamics,
privileged and oppressed,
which is why I was watching the young
Turks the other day.
In fact,
Jimmy Doyle,
I think it was a,
he,
he actually had his tongue in his mouth
and he was saying that he was for the
oppressed in every situation.
So he took the example of Israel.
So Israel oppressed as a Palestinian
man.
He's in February,
the Palestinian man.
And then if the Palestinian amount of
presses,
his wife,
he's a fair for the wife and it's just
like,
yeah,
but you've,
you've just said you are and are not in
favor of the Palestinian man there,
Jenny,
you know,
that is inherently cultural.
You can't,
you can't be in favor of the man and the
wife,
you know,
at the same time.
Which one are you in favor of?
You know,
it's that kind of,
it's got this inherent contradiction to
it and they don't seem to want to
acknowledge that.
Yeah,
and that's why as we've said for awhile
and now this,
this regressive ideology,
it's always putting narrative over fact.
That's really the most when you whittle
it down to what it really is,
it has to be narrative over fact.
So you just pick the most depressed and
then you get everybody on the ladder and
then that's how you judge everybody,
which is the reverse of judging a
minority within a minority and those are
the people that we should be for.
Yeah,
absolutely.
In the crazy thing about it as well is
that these things are inherently racist
and sexist and any other issue you want
to.
But the problem is that normally when
people think,
oh,
you're being a racist,
you think you're being racist to the,
I guess the oppressed if that's what you
want is called the minority who have
suffered from racial discrimination
past,
you know,
black people or you know,
you're pressing women or something like
that.
But racism and sexism,
despite what the regressives will tell
you,
I'm not structures or systems of power,
their principles,
their ideas,
they are,
they'll,
they'll ways of viewing the world and so
you can be racist to white people,
you can be sexist to men and vice versa.
And so it's this kind of,
let's say the narrative they've,
they've gone out of the way to redefine
a bunch of woods and then they have
cherry picked data points to arrive,
a nice location where they can say you
as a white man and not allowed to speak.
Why?
Because you're a white man and they will
literally turn around and tell you that
is not racist and sexist.
I think it's amazing.
You give them enough credit to say
they've picked these data points because
I think in most cases they haven't even
gotten that far.
You're,
you're giving them the benefit of the
doubt that I can no longer give them.
But we started here on feminism.
So let's not go too far.
But.
But that's the interesting thing that
every time I'm talking about all this
stuff,
we realize how the Inter.
There's this interlink theme between
Gamergate,
between feminism,
all of this stuff.
So,
uh,
as far as feminism,
I saw an interesting video that you did
where you took the three types of what
you said were the three types of male
feminists.
Um,
and I thought it was really interesting
because I was,
because I defend women,
I,
I believe women should be equal.
Uh,
and that's pretty much it,
so anyone can define me however they
want,
but I thought the way you broke these
three type of men down was pretty
interesting.
Can you do that for us?
Um.
Oh God,
it was while ago.
Did that video.
I can't remember it now.
Okay.
So yeah,
it's basically self interest I think.
I mean,
you get some,
you get men who are the,
they want to be rewarded for doing
something heroic and protective and I
think that a change might fall into this
category where he's easy.
He's a big guy,
he's not he himself,
that,
you know,
this doesn't have any particular fears
in,
for his own physical security.
And so he thinks I'm going to use my
physical presence to protect women
because that would be a,
a,
you know,
a laudable thing to do.
And it would be,
except that they're doing it for their
own self interests that don't get thrown
for the,
for their own personal feelings.
The other end of the day,
this is a guy who basically wants to get
laid.
I mean,
in a lot of respects,
I don't want to put it that way,
but yeah,
I kind of Miss.
It's,
the thing is it's not necessarily
getting lady though love.
A lot of it is just for just for the
sort of emotional reward,
you know,
because like a social.
Yeah.
And,
and just just,
um,
just to get the pat on the head,
you know,
it's,
it's kind of to feel good about
themselves,
but requires permission from someone
else.
This case being a woman.
And the thing is you end up,
you end up getting ready,
sort of,
um,
really unhealthy dynamics because you'll
find women who are looking for men to do
things for.
And you will find men who are looking to
do things for women and you will get
this kind of feedback loop where they'll
reinforce each other,
you know,
this,
this guy stands up for this woman who is
using him to fight her battles.
And so this guy ends up fighting battles
on his battles but are being reinforced,
constantly buy.
And again,
this is not like all women in most women
are not like this,
but you will,
you know,
women are humans too and you get bad
women as well as good women.
And you find that this,
this is basically one of the problems
with the progressive because like we
were saying earlier,
and I hate to come back to like
progresses,
but feminism is just one like brunch and
under the umbrella of the progressive
sort of tree,
I guess,
you know,
it's,
it,
it all ties together.
Um,
but you said you get most people when
they think they're doing it for the
right reasons.
You know,
they think,
well,
I'm a good person.
I need to be helping women in minorities
and gays and Trans and whatever.
But the,
the problem is that they have this kind
of toolbox of rhetoric that virtue
signals to other regressives.
It shows them say,
hey look,
I'm using this kind of language,
therefore I'm on your team.
You can come and support me on twitter
or wherever you know,
and,
and so you will get people who think,
okay,
great,
I'm going to do that because I'm always
wanting to be an activist onto something
good.
And then you'll get the other kind of
person who is the more malicious person
who will think,
great,
I can use this to my own advantage.
And they are the people you've got to be
really worried about.
I mean,
there's a.
In gamer gate,
there was a woman called Randy Harper.
She wasn't actually pop game gay.
She was part of the problem,
but some,
the,
the.
I've never seen it most starkly
represented than in her example,
I think it was 2011,
2012.
She,
uh,
she was on a BSD,
which is a programming language,
a podcast.
And she was literally saying,
well,
I'm a woman in tech and I don't have a
problem with this.
You know,
I think,
I think the feminists have of blowing
this problem with ms dot progeny and the
tech industry and all this other stuff.
I'm a women in tech.
I have no problem.
Everything's great.
And Lo behold,
two years later when it's shown to be a
profitable business model,
she is literally on twitter.
Say I'm an oppressed woman in Tech.
I need your money,
you know,
give me money every month through
patriots and also,
and the,
the,
just the complete polar opposite of what
you were saying before.
And it's like really?
So either the industry has become
massively sexist overnights.
You found a way to profit.
So you know,
and so,
so this is sort of something we could
find with any movement.
So I don't think,
I don't think you're saying this,
but that this isn't specific to
feminism.
Any movements can have.
It's people who are doing it with the
right intentions.
It's going to have the people that are
being guilted into it.
being tricked into it.
It's gonna have the people that can
profit from it all.
Every single movement.
And you're just using feminism is one
example.
I don't want people to say,
well,
you see,
he's,
he's trying to mock up what feminism is
or something to that effect.
Yeah.
No,
no,
you're right.
This,
this is again,
it's not necessarily feminism because
feminism is just a subsection of the
social justice movement.
You know,
you've got some,
they call it into sectionalism is like,
there's bell hooks describes it as the
white supremacist capitalist patriarchy.
I'm not surprising you are.
You are a supporter of the white
supremacist capitalist Patriarchy date.
I actually propagates.
I'm,
I'm a terrible person.
But basically what this encompasses is,
is,
uh,
the dynamics between black people and
white people.
The white supremacy,
a,
the capitalism is the poor and the rich
and the patriarchy being men and women.
Um,
I think they probably have terms for gay
and straight and Trans and CIS.
But I'm not familiar with them off the
top of my head,
but this is.
This is the point at some,
they have this toolbox of tubs and they
have a academic background.
All of this comes from academia.
All of this,
you know,
this has all been.
And People Think,
oh,
this is coming from tumblr.
It's like,
no,
tomorrow is the outgrowth of this
council.
You know,
this is coming to the surface in popular
culture.
This all comes from sorts of,
you know,
the halls of academia where they,
they start with a premise,
they confirm their biases,
the peer review,
that own papers between feminists and
then they carry on building from that
until they've got to the point where
they will,
like I said,
the redefinition of things.
The reason,
the reason the progressives are so
dangerous is of course,
as you said,
with every movement,
you're going to get people who are
profit,
Terry Union,
people doing it for their own selfish
reasons,
but I can't think of any movement that
legitimately has an excuse to be
malevolent to people for any good
reason.
You know,
almost every single one he let Christy
has been love.
You love your neighbor as yourself,
you know,
and like for very individualistic Zena
individual rights in representative
democracy,
everyone gets to be treated in a
universal,
you know,
the Brotherhood of man and all that sort
of thing.
Whereas these people have something
different.
They actually have,
and I,
I,
I can't remember which feminists that is
and I'm quoting and they say this,
I think it's Andrea.
Talk Him when they say that women have
the right to hate their oppresses.
Now this is for me a particularly scary
aspect of it.
And it goes,
it goes totally for what the black lives
matter movement,
who all subscribed to this kind of
ideology.
It's the,
it's the way of legitimizing hatred for
people based on what is perceived to be
social advantages.
So if they say,
well,
you're a white man,
therefore you have special lunches,
therefore it's not bad for me to hate
you.
You know I can,
I can say all sorts of things to you and
it's okay because you have privilege.
I'm oppressed.
You're privileged.
Therefore,
no matter what I say to you,
it doesn't matter,
even though in an interpersonal
interaction,
if you say some horrible things to me,
I'm helped by,
you know,
I'm a,
I'm a regular person.
Like my white privilege isn't actually a
shield from horrible word.
Also,
it,
it takes the distinction away from
someone from a male who is doing
everything he can to fight for women's
rights and equality.
And I'm an a man who is against those
things.
If you just say it's white men or it's
just men.
And we saw this,
a great example of this I think is a
couple of weeks ago with those Cologne
attacks,
and I saw all these feminists writing
articles and tweeting saying things are,
this is,
it's not a,
this isn't a migrant problem,
this isn't a religion problem.
They were doing everything to get it
away from the identity of the specific
people who did this and try,
this is a male problem.
Now this is crazy.
This is actually crazy.
It's insane.
What happened in Cologne was something
called Tara rush a,
which is just Arabic,
the group assault or sexual assaults.
Um,
and it's something that happens.
Think the first instance of it was,
I think it was originally recorded in
the fifties,
but I guess it kind of wasn't something
that really came to the surface until
about 2011 in the Egyptian Arab spring
where I,
excuse me,
I think it was a CNN journalist,
was basically surrounded by a group of
guys in,
uh,
in Cairo and then molested and forcibly
be molested by gangs of men.
And this,
this happened on New Year's Eve all
across Europe.
It happened in Stockholm,
Helsinki,
or attempted to in multiple German
cities.
And it was,
you know,
the,
the police chief literally said nothing
like this ever happened before.
And so when feminists say,
well,
this is just men,
we know that's wrong,
you know,
we,
we know that's when we know that it is
probably tied to retrograde attitudes
towards women coming from the Islamic
world.
You know,
I'm not saying every Muslim or anything
like that,
but you know,
you,
you can't go to the Islamic world and
look around and see how things are and
say that women are treated the same
there as they are here.
Right.
So,
so that's a perfect segue to this
feminist and is video that you had
mirrored.
Who was the guy that originally created
the video?
Right.
The video was originally done by a
small,
a small youtube called Seitan atheist.
Okay.
So He created this cartoon video and
it's a song and it's basically a
feminist and Islamist singing together
about why they sort of see the world in
the same way.
That was the thrust of it.
And I saw the video and before all hell
broke loose about it before Richard
Dawkins retweeted it,
I,
I saw it and I thought it was pretty
brilliant.
It's a great satirical takedown of this
regressive nonsense.
Now,
I didn't realize at the time that
apparently the,
the female character playing the piano,
apparently that was actually based off a
real person.
Right?
I didn't know that.
So the Islamist,
the Islamist is a youtuber called dollar
man who,
um,
he runs around proclaiming Islamism,
united saying that everyone should
bounce with Islam and all that sort of
thing.
So it wasn't,
it wasn't victimizing anyone in
particular in these parodies of
individuals,
but the individuals who have become
famous because of their terrible ideas
and Massachusetts.
Right.
Go ahead.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
I,
I had,
I would love to say that I wrote it or
something,
but I didn't.
I literally emailed the guy and said,
look,
I really like your channel.
I want to help promote you.
Do me a piece of unique content that I
can put my child wouldn't blink back to
you.
Um,
and so you sent me this video and I saw
it.
I put it up and uh,
and yeah,
and all hell broke loose when Richard
Dawkins retweeted it.
So basically all Dawkins did was retweet
this and suddenly his twitter feed blew
up and he was deep platform from a
speaking event at the.
Any CSS,
I think it's the northeast conference of
secular skeptics,
skeptics and secularism.
Something close to that.
He was the platform from it.
They applied for them without even
telling him.
There wasn't even a phone call.
They didn't ask for an explanation.
He then
he made a public statement to virtue
signal.
That's the important thing.
They were telling you,
the regressives look,
you know,
with d platforming him because he has
done something transgressive to us,
you know,
we won't show everyone else.
We're on where we're at the front
saying,
look,
this is a terrible thing.
The irony being Richard Dawkins was
probably a big draw for that place.
You know what I mean?
Of course,
you know,
he,
they might get three,
400 people that Richard Dawkins has
millions of followers,
you know,
he,
he's,
he's doing them a favor.
So the,
you know,
they haven't,
they,
they've kind of shot themselves in the
foot and they've just made themselves
with really intolerant because his
original tweet was obviously as a
feminist myself,
this doesn't apply to all feminists,
but there is definitely a pernicious
minority and low and behold the punishes
minority rose up and you know,
got in his face and it's like,
okay,
well you're just proving the point of
the video.
Right?
So you're literally proving the point of
the video.
You're literally proving that these two
groups for all the wrong reasons have
become partners.
That there's one ideology that,
that feminist unfortunately or some
degree of feminist seem to be okay with.
And it's the same ideology that would do
the worst to women.
Yes.
It's hard to.
It's hard to believe that we,
even as I'm saying it,
I'm thinking this is completely bonkers.
It is absolutely.
It's bunk.
I'm without intersection Islam.
It doesn't make any sense at all,
you know.
But when,
again,
you've got to thinking sexually,
so you think Ryan white person than
Brown person than men,
women and said,
okay,
what the question is,
what is the most oppressive thing,
so I'm am oppressed in the woman that's
quite bad,
but a white person,
the pressing a brown person that's much
worse and therefore now we're talking
about a bunch of Brown people being
oppressed by a bunch of white people,
and so the fact that men and women are
oppressing each other brown winter or
pressing white women,
that's so important.
The important bit is the skin color
above the sex,
which I'm genuinely surprised that I
thought feminist would go the other way.
I thought that they would be more
concerned about men oppressing women in
Lynn Brown.
People are being oppressed by white
people,
but apparently the.
No.
Yeah,
apparently not.
So in your estimation then,
knowing the way the feminist movement
has evolved,
and obviously I've had Christina Hoff
summers on the show and I've talked to
her about some of this stuff.
What would you say is the best?
If you just want true equality for the
sexes,
you're married to a woman,
you,
you like women,
heterosexual guy that likes women,
right?
Um,
what would you say is the best way for
men and for women,
for anyone that cares about the ideas of
feminism to go out and act on those
ideas?
Um,
I mean,
honestly,
I think one of the problems that
feminism has now,
modern feminism has,
this is one of dragons to slay,
you know,
I mean men,
men and women have complete legal
equality.
I can't think of it whenever,
whenever a feminist is challenging you
to say,
Oh,
you know,
the men are oppressing women.
Ask them what legal men have.
Women,
they can't leave it.
There just aren't any.
And so we're at the point now where,
I mean,
I,
I don't know what more needs to be done.
We seem to be living in quite stable
liberal democracies where merit methods.
I mean obviously in everything it is a
lot of,
a lot of what it is is who,
you know rather than what,
you know,
Butts,
merit,
still massive,
you know,
you can't just hire someone for that
arbitrary characteristics if they can't
do the job,
but you mean no one,
no one thinks that.
So,
I mean I'm personally,
I just think don't,
don't make judgments based on racial
gender or you know,
or transgenderism or you know,
or homosexuality or anything like that.
The,
these characteristics that Germany,
I'm very useful to judge people on.
I mean,
you know,
your,
your being a white man doesn't in any
way inform how good an inferior you are.
You know,
I,
I'm,
I'm not watching you because you're a
white man.
I'm watching you because I like the
guests you have on what the questions
you asked.
I let the ounces you get out with them.
You know,
none of that has anything to do with you
being white or male.
A straight.
Okay.
Or anything about this.
They,
they completely pointless and arbitrary
characteristics that really apply.
Right?
So really all we have to do is just keep
hammering the point home,
right?
If if were for people that want to
remove this identity politics stuff,
we just have to keep hammering that
until it becomes so obvious and I do
think that's where,
and this is where we can sort of pivot
to a little more of the regressive
tactics.
This is where we can really beat them.
They're tough to beat because we know
they're going to lie.
We know they're gonna cheat and
misinformed people and all of those
things,
but what we can keep hammering them with
is we want equality for everybody
regardless of borders and nationality
and religion and everything else.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the fundamentals of the fundamental
principles of liberalism,
a universal mats that,
that was the great.
The great gift of sort of English
liberalism is individual rights and
universal principles that you think are
wrong.
You know,
we've not always applied these evenly or
anything like this.
And you know,
initially they were exclusively for
white heterosexual men at the very top
of the pyramid.
But the point is that the principals
obviously lend themselves to cascading
downwards because as soon as you have
some people who are espousing these
principles,
there is no good reason not to extend
the franchise to everyone,
which is why we now have universal
suffrage.
It Yukon.
There's no justification to not united.
The on all of the justification is given
world,
obviously faulting,
which is why we're now at the point
where we are.
Um,
so yeah,
it just basically stay true to your own
principles.
If you think it's wrong to judge by
race,
don't judge people by race.
It doesn't matter what race they are.
If you think it's wrong to judge by
people,
by sex,
don't judge people by sex,
you know.
And,
and the,
all,
I,
all I can say is that these are timeless
principles that will always be relevant.
You know,
they will never be a time where someone
says,
you know,
actually it is because I'm black,
that I should be judged is because I'm a
woman that I should be.
And it's only because these people have,
they've got a lot of good and very
slippery language and techniques to
persuade people that in fact,
you know,
given this context,
it's right to do this.
Whereas I'm of the opinion that there is
no context in which its rights to judge
people based on characteristics they
have no control over if you didn't get
to choose it.
It's not a part of your character,
it doesn't describe you as a person,
it just describes your body or your,
you know,
your physical characteristics.
It doesn't describe what you are like in
your character.
So does this,
do you think this also goes to the
feeling part of this?
Because that's sort of what I'm thinking
as you're saying this,
that there is,
there is a feeling that I think this
regressive ideology is attached to.
So for example,
I can't give you a,
as you just said,
I can't give you an example of where
systemically in the United States that
women are oppressed,
meaning that,
you know,
there are now laws protecting,
equal opportunity laws and things like
that.
Now that doesn't mean that women don't
have a harder time related to certain
things.
If business deals,
for example,
are being done on golf courses and less
women play golf,
well then they're going to be excluded
and then you could probably think of
many,
many examples like that.
But what that is really more about is,
is a feeling not sort of a systemic
legal issue.
And I think that's where people,
that's where people struggle to separate
these things.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
I think like,
um,
uh,
what's the,
what's the company that does the sex
toys and some.
And some of this is a British company.
I think it,
it sounds sex toys.
It's,
it was created by a woman and a large
portion of the company is run by women.
They probably don't do that business
deals on golf courses,
you know,
they,
they probably have,
I don't know,
mass on nail salons or something like,
so,
you know,
and I'm saying stereotypical,
but they don't go to the golf courses.
So I would have to change my position
and perspective and I would have to go
to where the power is in that situation.
You're right.
And you know,
they're,
they're all going to be cases where you
have um,
you know,
powerful ceos who go golfing and the way
to get into the good graces would be to
go go from as well.
Um,
you know,
sometimes you've got to make sacrifices.
I,
I personally hate golfing,
but I wanted to be the CEO of this
company will get,
you know,
I went to work my way up the ladder.
I would take up golfing.
You know,
it doesn't matter about your gender,
it matters about how well you'd go,
you know.
So,
you know,
I,
like I said,
it's not a perfect system either,
but it's better than the alternative
because one thing that people were out
of my quotes is as soon as you start
discriminating in favor of someone
because of skin color,
sex,
ethnicity,
whatever,
you will also discriminating against
people on those very same categories.
You know,
if you say,
right,
we've got a position here and we need to
hire a black woman,
then you're excluding people on the
basis of their race and sex.
So I,
I can't agree with that.
I think that's wrong.
If I'm sure there are plenty of
incredibly talented black women out
there,
therefore we don't need to make
artificial adjustments.
Surely,
you know,
and at the end of the day,
if we go down this road,
then when does it end?
Where,
where is the eventual logical goal?
Eventually you come to a planned
economy.
What you can't,
you can't just have honor.
We,
you were going to hire by merit,
but now you've got 10 different
categories you've got to go through,
you know,
how many,
how many trans people,
Queer people,
how many black,
white,
Hispanic,
you know.
And so now you're talking about how good
they are at their jobs.
Now you're talking about the just
operatory characteristics of these
people.
And what happens when,
like if three people leave,
once you do three black people,
leave your company and all you have
applying for jobs,
uh,
white people,
what do you,
do?
You know,
you're in a position where it's,
it's ridiculous.
Yeah,
it's really crazy.
It's almost like the,
the quest for equality is being played
sort of on an unequal playing field and
that just makes everybody kind of nuts.
Well,
I think,
I think nature really didn't have it
right when he,
when he was saying that,
um,
you know,
be careful when you're battling monsters
because when you stand along into the
abyss,
the bissell sustains into you.
You're not.
And if you,
if you stand along into the sort of
progressive mindset of the world is
terribly uneven,
it's an unequal.
There are no opportunities for anyone.
There's no ed.
We need to do anything we can to help
them.
Then everything becomes justified.
You know,
the,
it doesn't matter whose rights you're
trump alone,
you're doing it for the greater good.
And that's what really scared.
So that's actually a great segue to.
I want to talk about a little bit about
their tactics.
So I think in the,
in the 45 minutes or so that we've been
talking,
we've talked a lot about their ideas and
obviously we're not fans of their ideas,
but I think there's something more
pernicious going on here with some of
the tactics because I don't think it's a
coincidence that many of the main
players in this regressive left
movement,
uh,
have been exposed to be liars,
to be plagiarists,
to be frauds,
to purposely manipulate people's words,
to create memes that are knowingly
misquoted all of these things.
I don't think that's a coincidence.
Now you may disagree what with what
Sargon of Akkad says,
or what Dave Rubin says,
but I don't think you would find
instances where we maliciously
misrepresented people.
And I suppose they're just their
argument if you really got them alone,
if you could really get an honest moment
out of them,
which I don't know you could get,
but I suppose their argument would be,
well,
the ends justify the means and that's
just the reverse of how I view the
world.
Yeah,
no,
that is honest.
Honestly,
that's exactly what it is,
right?
It's about it.
They're the,
there's a lot to unpack here actually.
There's these people are being primed in
universities to be activists and part of
the priming is to give them a good
feeling about doing this activism.
You know,
it's to make them think that they can
emotionally reward themselves by saying,
yeah,
I argued with a misogynist on twitter,
you know,
for,
oh no,
I'm not kidding there.
That genuinely is.
I've seen feminist,
I've seen pictures of feminists courses
were on the wall.
They have a big twitter activism is
feminism and stuff like this and it's
just like,
really?
That's the thing.
They're encouraged to be activists.
They are encouraged to emotion and
reward themselves for being activists
and stuff.
Do you know like theory about never
argued with a twitter egg.
That's what I'm going to put on my
tombstone one day.
I,
I haven't heard that,
but that's a good one because I,
I,
I care about ideas and not like people
are numbers so I can't wait when someone
would like five fullest as your role in
this.
I've got to argue the case.
I've got to stop out.
Wow.
I might be a little more evolved than
you.
That's pretty good.
Um,
what was I saying?
that at the schools that,
there,
there's this,
there's an intellectual incentive or
there's a feeling incentive.
Yeah,
there's an emotional incentive and um,
basically it's,
they've got to the point where they've
convinced themselves that progressive or
regressive ism is the only morally
legitimate position to hold.
And so anyone not holding this position
must be a bad person.
And that's everything about
progressivism in a nutshell right there.
If you a regressive,
you are a bad person.
If you owns sacrificing other people's
rights for the rights of a group that
you don't know you've got no connection
to,
but you have been emotionally primed to
fight for,
then you're a bad person.
And so it's okay for me to call you all
these terrible labels.
I mean,
I,
you would have to be pretty damn racist
for me to call you a racist,
you know,
it's a bad label.
It's a label with a lot of weight and
yet these people throw around as if it
means nothing.
You know?
You know,
I,
I always say that I,
I think I said this to you when I was on
your show that my awakening had a lot to
do with that whole Ben Affleck,
Sam Harris thing on real time and,
and part of what the craziness of was
with that was that ben throughout
racists so quickly that I agree with
you,
it would take a lot.
It would take a lot.
There are obvious racist out there and
they should be called out,
but if you were arguing with someone,
it would take a real special person for
them to eliminate that.
They were racist within 30 seconds.
I mean,
yeah,
I can only imagine.
Then that came straight out of the gate
with it or something and they were like,
yeah,
okay.
Black people should be under,
shipped off the cotton plantations or
something.
Be like,
okay,
well you're a racist.
And on the blood,
well I wouldn't call myself and
whatever,
but some of these things normally hold a
lot of weights and the.
And that's the reason they use.
They use labels as weapons and they did
it for a reason,
for a couple of reasons.
Actually.
The first one obviously is to put you on
the back foot.
As soon as you're called a racist or
homophobic or bigger or whatever.
Then you're defending yourself.
You're not defending your ideas.
You're not attacking their ideas.
You're defending yourself as a person.
I mean,
that's in itself a logical fallacy
called an ad hominem attack the person
rather than the ideas,
and you will find that they do this a
lot.
So basically,
right?
The answer to this is to just say in
your opinion on the end of it,
so they'll say you're a racist and you
say,
well,
in your opinion,
right?
But they'll say,
you know,
you're a racist or sexist or bigoted.
So in your opinion,
you know,
I'm not lots and I know him and nothing
that I've said would make any reasonable
person thing,
but you other nodal reasonable person
and therefore you're going to label me
as a racist or a bigot or whatever.
And honestly what you've just given me
is your opinion.
It's not an objective statement of fact.
It's like when they use the word
programmatic,
they'll say,
oh,
that's problematic.
And like,
well,
can you explain to me what programmatic
means?
Immoral.
Does it mean wrong?
Doesn't mean illegal?
No.
It means transgressive to progressivism
with feminism and it's basically the
same as sinful in the Catholic church or
it's the same as in Islam,
you know,
it's,
it's the,
this is transgressive to my ideology is
something wrong and it's not an
objective statement of fact.
It's,
I don't like what you've done.
Right.
So that I,
I love that because it goes to show that
they want in a certain intellectual or
ideological purity and that's what the
Church would want out of your or any
sort of authoritarian view would want an
intellectual and ideological peer,
not intellectual,
purely ideological purity.
It's usually not that intellectual,
right?
No,
absolutely.
They want an ideological ideological
purity out of you.
And what that does,
you know,
I'm seeing this right now in our
democratic debate last week between
Bernie and Hillary.
They were arguing over who's the bigger
progressive and it's like,
guys,
that's not what the fight should be
about.
It should be about,
if you're on the left,
it should be about who is standing up
for liberal principles,
more,
not who fits this narrow definition
because guess what then all you do,
as we've said a zillion times in your
hand,
the debate over to the right and
absolutely,
and yet Donald Trump,
the steering in their own juices there
as well.
He's,
I know I'm the biggest procrastinator.
Salute you.
You don't need to.
You don't need to worry about convincing
people about who's the bigger
progressive progressive's aren't going
to vote for you.
You know,
liberals are the people you want to
commence on the swing.
Voters who are dying,
you know,
died in the more progressive than the
people who,
you know,
who,
who concerned about issues.
Okay.
Said about policies,
you know,
who can send about what you're actually
going to do rather than,
you know,
ideological Brownie points.
And so yeah,
it's,
it's just this little circle jerk with a
student or an ideology for so long.
They don't understand how they're being
viewed from the outside.
I let you said it's driving people to
the right.
You know,
it's absolutely driving people.
So then what,
what do we do?
Because that is not us,
right?
We're the ones,
we're the ones that are trying to defend
classical liberalism.
I'm sure you get tons of emails and
tweets and all that stuff that I get all
the time about.
I see this split,
this has happened.
I get people telling me they're afraid
and embarrassed to call themselves on
the left.
I get other people saying they won't
post things on facebook because they
don't want to get called a racist.
So all of these things.
So if there's this growing group of
people,
which there absolutely is,
I have no doubt about it.
Uh,
what,
what do we do to keep this message
going?
Okay.
Um,
okay.
So the great thing about what's
happening is that the,
it's interesting because,
I mean,
like I said,
you had Milo Yiannopoulos on your show.
He was a,
he was the only journalist who was
prepared to cover gamergate initially.
And I've,
I've grown to become friends with them
and people find it really.
Oh,
because he's a conservative and I'm a
liberal and I just tried to explain to
them that look,
right,
we've come to the point where it's not
really about political affiliation to
left and right.
It's about whether we can agree on
reality,
you know,
we can interpret this reality and have
our own opinions in any way.
I'm sure that he's got a lot of
opinions,
things that I disagree with,
so if we can agree that the numbers are
such that the events are as follows,
you know,
whereas the progressive left will lie to
you.
They will lie to themselves like that
what we said that will cherry pick their
narrative.
They'll choose several data points,
leave out the ones that contradict what
they've said,
and then if you don't agree with that
narrative,
they consider you persona non grata.
You're,
you're,
you may as well be,
you know,
bill o'reilly or something like that in
that month.
Just to be very clear,
you're not just,
you're not just saying something for the
sake of saying it.
I mean,
I have literally seen this happen to me
just to be very clear.
I mean,
this is exactly what's happened to me,
which I now wear as a badge of pride,
by the way.
Yes.
Well,
let.
This is one of the things when you first
introduce people to this and they don't
know anything about sales.
I honestly think there's a lot of.
They,
they protect themselves with audacity
and I mean I,
I'm a big fan of military history and
audacity is one of those things that
wins many wars because it's so
unexpected and I really think that the
things they do are so audacious that
it's hard to persuade people that
genuinely doing them because people hear
it and think,
I would never do that.
No,
do that.
You know,
I wouldn't do it.
I can't imagine anyone doing it.
That's not happening your life,
you know,
and they think that the person relating
the information is the one telling the
lie.
And so the progressives,
I think,
you know,
they really,
really take a couple this and say,
well that's because he's a racist and
sexist and all these things.
And then the person that has to
experience them acting as they act to
read.
I've had so many people come back and we
get mad.
I thought you were full of nonsense
when,
uh,
when I first had to,
but that was exactly how they are.
Exactly how they.
And I'm like,
yeah mate,
I told you honestly,
don't worry about it,
you know,
just.
No,
no,
no harm,
no foul sort of thing.
It's,
it happens to everyone because at first
when you first hear it sounds like
nonsense,
you can't believe anyone would act this
way.
And yet they do.
Do you sometimes think that maybe the
best way to beat them at this point is
just to ignore them?
Because I think over the last six months
between what we do here,
what you do,
what many other people are doing,
especially in the digital space now and
what Bill Maher has done a little bit
more in the mainstream,
there's been,
they've been exposed and I think because
as you said,
they're stewing in their juices now.
Part of me is just like,
Eh,
let,
let's just ignore them and then,
you know,
then there's another piece of me that
says we have to keep on the attack.
Which do you think would be a better,
uh,
offering them as a very dangerous
tactic?
I think the,
the,
the problem,
the problem with that is that you have
the initiative to them and you say,
you know,
I'm,
I'm not gonna pay attention,
excuse me,
to what you're doing.
And therefore whatever it is they do and
you're not really aware of and suddenly
something will come at you that you're
not prepared for.
I.
And also it gives them the ground to
continue propagating their ideological
position that gets them,
you know,
there's no,
there's no resistance.
And so,
I mean,
it's,
it own twists a yeah,
she'll eat it.
Maybe.
Maybe there's little resistance.
But like if,
if you get a group,
a little delegation of progressives who
come to a place and they say,
oh,
we'd like to talk to you about women's
equality,
or you call it,
go on,
then you know.
And so your boss might like,
you know,
he's just a good guy.
He doesn't know.
He's just,
Oh,
right,
okay,
well I'll do whatever I can.
You know.
And suddenly these people are now
advising the upper echelons of this
company and then they stopped enforcing
ideological conformity and then suddenly
you're in this position where,
I mean this happened to major game
studios has happened to like games
workshop.
It's there,
there are,
there are lots of people who have fallen
prey to the velvet glove of social
justice that contains within it the iron
fist.
But it's just really well hidden.
So no,
I don't think we can just,
I think we have to fight them when we
have to show people that there is a
better alternative knots,
the eternal point you've,
you've got to provide a better
alternative.
And universal liberal principles,
in my opinion,
are the highest alternative there.
There isn't anything better.
You can't get anything more fair than
normal liberal principles.
So I,
I honestly think just just pushing
these,
you know,
showing people these are the best way to
do things in this not only encourages
equal treatment of people into the law
and any kind of social situation,
but it also,
it also pushes people to be the best
that they can be.
It doesn't encourage them to be victims,
it doesn't hurt them to get,
to be depressed and to,
to milk it,
you know,
there's no room for fraud when you come
to these sorts of meritocratic
principles.
People have to work,
they have to push themselves and become
better.
And it's about raising the human
condition rather than dragging it down,
which is everything about regressing.
Yeah.
Well naturally I believe in what you're
saying and that's why I'm doing what I'm
doing.
So I really,
more than anything else,
I should thank you because,
you know,
there were a couple key people that
helped my awakening and when I had that
conversation with you,
a on your channel,
that was one of the first times that I
really started talking about this stuff.
Uh,
so you were definitely a key piece in
that,
so I appreciate that.
Uh,
and I appreciate all the work you do and
everyone can find out more of SAR guns.
Take on gamer gate,
feminism,
regressives and plenty more over on his
youtube channel,
which is youtube.com/Sargon
of a cod 100 and Sargon Karl.
Or do you have any other names that I
need to know about?
Let's just say those are the big two.
All right,
well I appreciate it and thank you guys
for watching and we'll do it again next
week.